und wenn ich jetzt noch mal ein gebe
stütz blogger mein pc
hallöchen meine lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen hier zu einer
weiteren folge von den microsoft
commerce heute hier selbstverständlich
ich freue mich echt das ist so richtig
wochen ein stimmung ist so richtig gutes
wetter draußen also die sonne ist schon
untergegangen aber es war heute richtig
geiles wetter draußen jedenfalls wurde
mir auch wieder viele command zugesendet
und m
ich will mich freuen wenn du bist meine
dran bleibt und wir sehen uns dann jetzt
bei dem ersten command ich gebe mir
natürlich hier erstmal einen command
block und üblicherweise wie es üblich
ist noch ein hebel und da kommt auch
schon zum ersten command der mir zu
gesendet wurde von leonel 007 und zwar
sport dieser command einen riesenhunger
dafür brauche ich jetzt noch gar nicht
diese command blog ich flieg ich erst
mal nach oben und zeigt euch überhaupt
was tages bauen wir das wieder sehr sehr
cool aus
mit dem nebel und so meinen in einigen
ecken
ich baue jetzt hier nämlich mal das was
ihr hier schon sieht und es kommt ein
riesiger wieder ihr seht schon sehr sehr
groß und versinkt im boden wo wir da hin
hallo okay okay okay okay ich zeige es
euch noch ein bisschen weiter oben als
spawnen villa
wir sehen schon in wald 10.000 also der
ist sehr sehr groß sehr viel größer
diesen wird er das seht ihr auch schon
weil das da oben ein gelände entsteht
und der ist irgendwie auf dem kopf und
der fliegt nach unten also dass er nach
unten fliegt weiter testen nicht aber
wir sehen schon ich muss auch nah dran
sein damit er nicht irgendwie doch ihr
seht schon ja der fliegt nach unten de
ridder
das ist ein bisschen komisch aber es
wird auf jeden fall einfach ein riesiger
weiter gespannt ich finde diese teile
sind so eklig auch mit diesem wackelnden
schwanz und
wackelt der schwanz gut luca de freund
also das ist nummer eins wir sehen schon
dass sein schwanz der dann noch so ein
bisschen immer teil zu sehen ist doch
auf der höhe bleibt jetzt wahrscheinlich
hat er den boden erreicht oder so wie
crazy gehören auch hier schon wieder
komische sounds und alles mögliche und
so weiter und so fort
das ist auf jeden fall nummer eins ganz
easy familien einfach ein riesiger roter
der export wird und irgendwie auf dem
kopf ist und irgendwie runter fliegt und
was weis ich ein bisschen crazy ist das
ganze auf jeden fall schon das ganze
wurde mir zu kleinen von leonel 007 und
zwar und ich würde sagen die machen dann
auch schon direkt weiter mit command
nummer hat nummer zwei wurde mir von
einer person zugesendet die am liebsten
anonym bleiben möchte ich fliege mal
hier kurz ein bisschen von dem blöden
wittern da weg dass sie nicht die ganze
zeit so komisch rumschreien und zwar
kann man damit jeden x-beliebigen blog
auf seinen kopf setzen das ist ein recht
simpler command mal wieder aber auch
eigentlich ich weiß nicht ob denn jeder
schon kannten zwar einfach / replacement
ezb also hätte ich es player vs player
erwischte wohl dann einfach slot am ohr
hat also das was dadurch ersetzt werden
soll also der kopf soll durch einen
minecraft doppelpunkt zaun ersetzt
werden sich jetzt enter drücken sie
schon ich habe auf meinem kopf steigen
und das gleiche kann ich jetzt noch
einfacher machen wenn ich da
beispielsweise anstatt stone mal
beispielsweise wohin schreibe dann habe
ich eine wolle auf dem kopf oder ihr
seht ihr hier einfach minecraft
doppelpunkt glas steht ihr
beispielsweise da kann ich mir dann auch
rein theoretisch so ein glas auf den
kopf setzen das ist eigentlich ganz cool
und zwar ich weiß nicht das sieht dann
so aus als würde ich irgendwie welche
unter wasser wer als wäre ich dann
wirklich wie soll unter wasser
typen die so oder so naja ich sehe jetzt
nicht wirklich aus wie ein taucher aus
wie ein williger mit dem glas auf den
kopf der denkt er seinen taucher also
das kann man wirklich mit jedem block
machen ich frag mich ob es auch möglich
ist mitnehmen so was wie im lava einmal
ist es wahrscheinlich nicht möglich weil
wenn es damit möglich wäre dann wüsste
ich auf jeden fall nicht wie es aussehen
opel lava unterstrich bucket nee das
geht nicht das steht der konnte slot
plan nicht mit lava ersetzen
aber ich kann so was den bieten nehmen
das kann ich auf jeden fall nehmen dass
die dann wahrscheinlich auch wieder ein
bisschen crazy aus ich gebe mal hier
eben bieten ein da diese schon ach das
ist wahrscheinlich gehen ja ja klar ist
er genauso weil der bieten block wieder
sehr mit leicht verstört man kann zwar
nicht wirklich sehen aber freunde mir
sprießt ein setzlinge aus dem kopf sie
zu hause die so eine dauerwelle
irgendwie so grün dauerwelle gut ja
freunde das war jetzt auf jeden fall
command nummer zwei wir machen jetzt
direkt weiter mit 3,2 wurde mir von
einer person zu sein wie ich schon
gesagt habe die anonym bleiben möchte
und wir machen ja
nummer drei wurde mir von einer person
zugesendet die nicht anonym bleiben
möchte zwar heißt diese person refresh
einfach und es ist auch ein recht
simpler command also die command heute
recht simpel aber trotzdem interessant
weil ich denke nicht dass einige wussten
ist natürlich dass man seinen kopf
dadurch ersetzen kann durch irgend einen
blog aber ich denke viele wusste ist
auch nicht bis irgendwo schon mal
gesehen habe sich gefragt wie es geht
ich möchte euch halt quasi nur
vorstellen allgemein zum thema commands
vorstellen komme ich beim 5
nochmal der gema der geilste ist aber da
gab es doch nicht das boot aber unseren
kleinen nun klein nicht
auseinandersetzung eine diskussion sei
seit sarah komme gleich zu jedenfalls
ist mir zu ende von refresh und zwar ja
ihr werdet glaube ich schon an den
tieren hier sehen was dieser command
macht und zwar bekommt jeder entity
einen tnt auf den kopf also ich bin auch
ein entity deswegen war bei mir gab auch
seine tnt und zwar einfach überall
also ja wenn ich jetzt beispielsweise
mal hier durch den dschungel fliege oder
so seht ihr das hier beispielsweise auch
eine explosion ist oder ist da oben eine
gewesen da war vielleicht auch noch eine
hier unten war auf jeden fall noch eine
explosion am start da sehen wir schon da
sind ein paar items übrig aber da sind
auch einige scharfe hier noch übrig und
zwar sehe jetzt wenn ich den cut noch
mal ein gebe das bond einfach tnt auf
den entities drauf warum da vorne da
zuviel tätiges pontus weiß ich gar nicht
mal als ob da so viele entities waren
vielleicht dass das wäre jetzt
vielleicht werden diese blöcke da als
entwickler
aha liegende blöcke werden ja auch als
entities angesehen stimmt deswegen hat
wundert es wird immer so geruckelt weil
da einfach bei der explosion von einem
tier war ja erst mal nur ein tier was
sind die auf dem kopf hat deswegen liegt
am anfang alles flüssig aber da jetzt
durch die explosion der wieder 20.000
items auf dem boden liegen werden die
auch wieder alle explodiert und wenn ich
jetzt noch mal ein gebe stützt locker
mein pc gerade da silva doch martin de
facto gilt diese als rudel wieso ok
freundin der pc hat sich so in etwa
wieder beruhigt wir sehen hier schon
hier waren so ein paar entities und ihr
seht schon jetzt hier unten diese ganze
blöcke die hier so rumliegen sind jetzt
halt auch wieder entities also da
kriegen wir einfach alle endlich etwas
auf den kopf also nicht nur mob sondern
auch beispielsweise in rüstung ständer
oder an meinen part et cetera pp oder
halt einfach auch umliegende blöcke oder
ich selber und würde ich auch schon
sagen das war chromat nummer 3 der mit
zugesendet wurde von refresh einfach ein
command wo jeder entity ein tnt auf dem
kopf bekommt und ja dann will ich auch
schon sagen direkt 4,4 wurde mir
zugesendet von ta dion und zwar es ist
ein spor na also ein spanner wird
gespannt ich zeig euch erstmal hier so
zac damit euch mal ein fachteam
satellite weil ich denke dass die nur
bei nacht spawnen jahr da sind social
spot und zwar sehen wir schon das sind
einfach fliegen die skelette also die
reiten quasi auf solchen fledermäusen
rum an sich wissen wir ja schon das
haben wir der erste oder zweite folge
schon gelernt einfach es gibt ja diesen
riding coma hat also das einfach einen
mob einen anderen mans bereitet und das
ist hier der fall
es sieht aber trotzdem recht cool aus
und es erinnert mich irgendwie deswegen
habe ich angenommen an todesser von
harry potter natürlich todesser fliegen
zwar auch rum aber sind schwarze leute
mit umhängen und was weiß ich und
komische einfach todesser halt so wie
sie jeder kennen diese kumpanen ab und
bot und so deswegen max wird übrigens
umbringt kran crafter weil der weiß
alles besser in harry potter als
irgendwo auf der welt und ich habe
bestimmt irgendwas falsch gesagt jetzt
irgendwie falsch toren und jetzt kommt
der bessere ist ja auch egal jedenfalls
macht dieser command halt einfach einen
sportler der fliegende skelettes bzw
skelette auf fledermäusen und
ich finde damit kann man auf jeden fall
auf einem server wenn man mit kumpel auf
dem server zock ich mache jetzt nicht
aber vielleicht machen einige mit euch
irgendwo server oder so ich kann es euch
hier nochmal zeigen wenn ich mit 1 0
machen damit ihr seht nicht dass ihr
durch die komische youtube verarbeitung
gar nicht sehen könnt oder so hier sind
fliegende skelette überall und damit
kann man bestimmt den ein oder anderen
ganz gut rollen
apropos trollen da kommt gleich der
nächste command aber das ist erst mal
kommen vier die teile sterben auch
gleich die haben natürlich so ein paar
buhs an oder ich bin mir gar nicht mal
sicher kann auch sein dass sie gar nicht
sterben
doch ich dachte die hat mir zur busan
mit mit fiery sind aber hätten den helm
auf haben müssen
das wäre nochmal viel cooler gewesen
wenn im norden von helm aufgehabt hätten
ja also das ist auf jeden fall command
nummer vier da kommen so fliegen die
skelette einfach bei rum und die spawn
halten wie nur bei nacht also wenn ihr
seht wenn ich jemand einem set 20.000
mache dann spawnen die gleich wieder bei
nacht und beim tag explodieren kann die
spd nicht aber verbrennen anhalt
dementsprechend sind auf jeden fall ganz
cool fliegendes glätte kann man bestimmt
den einen oder anderen mit schocken
offen zu aber sollen dinge einfach macht
natürlich wieder alle in der
beschreibung und wir machen auch direkt
weiter mit dem troll command nummer 5,5
wurde mir nicht zugesendet von lotta
minecraft oder ebay minecraft oder wie
auch immer man ihn aussprechen kann
sorry falls du das video grad siehst ich
weiß nicht genau wie man einen namen
ausspricht sondern es wurde mir mal
wieder von einer anderen person
zugesendet die nicht credit gegeben hat
dann jay minecraft und zwar das ist das
was ich vorhin erwähnt hatte und zwar
dieses mit den sachen klauen
natürlich ist es so wenn irgendwo sachen
seht ja dann cool dann könnt ihr mir das
natürlich senden aber dann bitte immer
die auch die quelle angeben also dann
sagen ja hey luca hier nicht nicht so
wie es dieser person gemacht hat ich
möchte nicht sagen aber jemand hat man
in das formular geschrieben dass
commands formular so was in die richtung
hey luca ich habe hier ein toller
disaster for lange dran schickten pace
bin davon von dem command und ich
natürlich nicht dumm weil in der letzten
folge hatte ebay minecraft oder oder
minecraft adeya minecraft ich ja mein
freund ich weiß nicht genau hat es schon
kommentierte meinte ja das ist echt cool
und so alles aber da clown halt leute
meine kommerz und senden sie dir zu als
wären sie ihre
hans deswegen sorry doch eine
persönliche entschuldigung wenn das so
geht über facebook die persönliche
entschuldigung an dich halt quasi dass
da leute die hand genommen haben als
ihren ausgegeben haben um mir dann
geschickt haben finde ich selber ein
bisschen kaka aber ich kann das ganze
halt nahezu nicht kontrollieren ob das
jetzt einer cloud oder nicht deswegen
freunde wenn ihr demnächst irgendwelche
commands habt ihr gut findet oder so von
irgendeinem anderen youtuber der
minecraft oder was weiß ich dann mir
einfach zu sehen aber dann sagen ja den
habe ich aber von dem und dem das ist ja
nicht schlimm dann rw nicht der
beschreibung und das ist ja dann quasi
nun pusch an die also ich finde einfach
dass minecraft ich keine ahnung recht
genau wieder ausgesprochen wird jetzt
dass der echt somit die besten commands
macht und ich zeigen euch erstmal so ist
hier schon eingeben ich drücke hier
drauf das wird die immer eine maschine
gespannt weil das ja wieder so richtig
viele command blöcke in anspruch nimmt
also da kommt ein neuer command block
der dann wieder durch den reaktorblock
aktiviert wird und dieser und dieser und
dieser und dann sehen wir jetzt hier
schon stark maschinen da kommt gleich
ein button drauf hoffentlich mal da ist
der button kommen einfach drauf drücken
und wir bekommen wieder das inventar
ausgetauscht durch mega viele items und
zwar sind diese items die tri team
werden hier beispielsweise schwer etwas
irgendeinem ob mit einem hit tötet wir
haben ja eine zombie-invasion wir haben
hier lightning bolt wir haben fries wir
haben pressen wir haben john fust
webtrekk wir haben kiel entities around
über haben mega viele sachen die einfach
so ein bisschen das roll kit darstellen
sollen finde ich mega mega coole idee
ich hole mir jetzt erst mal hier mal ein
sportec um hier mal einfach in schwei zu
erschaffen woran ich euch das dann immer
zeige und zwar erstmal das schwer zu
glauben selbst erklären einmal
draufschlagen schweines tod das hat
einfach mega viele mega viel
schärfe und was alles dann haben wir
hier die lightning bolt das in meinem
text pecci aber beziehungsweise in
meinem pass ist dass das linear gala
oder was ist das mit beim niagara
ok ich lasse ich kann mit dem shader
halt blitze nicht wirklich darstellen
also ich hab's ausgestellt weil es beim
leben server imam regnen bauen dann hat
mich der regen aufgehört genervt so hat
das richtig hier meine lieben freunde da
man muss die bälle immer so ein bisschen
weiter wegschmeißen und dann kommt diese
dieser lightning bolt sie kommen nämlich
in einem gewissen abstand als ich werfe
den dahin so und da kommen die gerichte
und quasi lightning bolt seht ihr hier
so da und da an die richtung und so also
dass die lightning bolt dann hier fries
das ist einfach dass alle spieler auf
einem server sich nicht mehr bewegen
können außer ich selber also dass jedes
oczipka erst an aufbrausend und move
expect for you kill de vries pixomondo
die effekt also ich müsste jetzt das
schweinchen töten dann ist der effekt
sei wieder weg dann könnte sich jeder
wieder bewegen
dann haben wir hier auch noch prison das
ist einfach wenn ich hin setzte schon
kommt entweder sowas oder dann gibt es
auch noch webtrekk also kann ich auch
den setzen da kommen halt so diese
spinnen weben quasi dann haben wir hier
einfach das ganz normale erschaffen das
schwein und dann einfach gelände die
surround view das einfach alle tiere um
einen herum töten also wenn ich hier
beispielsweise ein schwein ins vorne
fehlte schon kann ich einfach mit kuren
setzen und dann sind alle entities tod
das spricht meine ich dann halt einfach
auch für alle entities bald also auch
brüstung ständer etc ich bin natürlich
ein game mode aber das ist das roll kit
meine lieben freunde damit kann man auf
jeden fall den einen oder anderen sehr
gute rollen auf einem server zumindest
weil sonst werden so ein paar sachen wie
friseur so würden gar nicht richtig zur
geltung kommen hier irgendwie sowas
ich würde einfach sagen weil ihm freuen
wenn ihr coole commands kennt oder auch
nicht mal selbst aus glas sondern von
irgend einem anderen youtube oder
irgendwas schickt sie mir einfach zu
aber immer credit geben immer sagen ja
das ist von dem und dem das ist ja nicht
schlimm dann sah ich halt einfach ja da
wird mir zu gesehen von dem ist aber
rein theoretisch wiegt jetzt vom dem und
so das ist ja nicht schlimm wenn ihr das
war einfach dazu schreibt ich möchte
euch eine vorstellen
und wenn die von einem anderen youtuber
sind dann bin ich froh dass ich ihn
damit so ein bisschen
ich weiß nicht so bei euch erwähnen
konnte das eventuell mal vorbeischaut
oder so finde ich auf jeden fall richtig
cooler
und wenn euch die folge gefallen hat
übrigens würde ich mich über eine
bewertung freuen ist ein kleiner klick
meine softbox geht gleich schon wieder
den geist auf ihr ich habe mich ich habe
schon so toll auf dem tisch dass ich
meine maus bewegt halter das ist sehr
stark und dann sehen uns in einem
nächsten video wieder ich war übrigens
beim friseur ich habe hier mega kurz die
haare trägt mich selber ein bisschen auf
aber die wachsende wieder nach ist eine
sehr schöne landschaft übrigens ne